good afternoon everybody happy Friday
okay so today was a historic day for the
country we should all be proud of
Justice contagi Brown Jackson and her
historic investiture to the United
States Supreme Court more than a hundred
justices have served on the on the
United States Supreme Court over the
past 200 years but today for the first
time Americans and people across the
world will see four women sitting on the
bench and today for the first time
Americans will see a black woman serving
on our nation's highest court
this is a proud day for America for our
democracy and in particular for women
and black women this fulfills major
promises President Biden made to help
make sure our Supreme Court bench
reflects the diversity of our nation and
more broadly to strengthen the Judiciary
by fighting to nominate and confirm
federal judges at a fast rate he
promised his nominees would be
experience committed to the rule of law
and that they would represent diverse
personal and professional backgrounds
since taking office President Biden has
made 143 nominations 84 have been
confirmed which is standout progress and
of his 143 nominees 68 percent have been
women and 66 percent are people of color
he's nominated groundbreaking first who
would be the first black Latino and aapi
judge to serve in their circuit or
District around the country today as we
celebrate Justice kataji Braun Jackson
investiture we also want to celebrate
the many others across the country
making history and the president is
going to keep building on what he sees
as one of his proudest accomplishments
and he thanks the senate for their
leadership on this issue as well
finally as as you heard directly from
president from the president a short
time ago our hearts are with everyone
impacted by Hurricane Ian and also
hurricane Fiona the president remains in
regular touch with the state and local
officials and spoke with Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and South Carolina
Governor Henry McMaster this morning
FEMA administrator Deanne Criswell is
also on the ground in Florida today
since before the storm made landform
President Biden has been clear that it
is a priority for the entire
Administration to get those impacted by
the storm help that they need one week
ago the President issued an emergency
declaration for Florida which meant we
could pre-position teams and resources
like food water and generators on the
ground yesterday the president did the
same thing for South Carolina in
anticipation of the storm hitting there
currently if currently ever efforts are
focused on saving lives and search and
rescue as part of an unprecedented level
of coordination with the Florida
National Guard and state and local
responders teams started search and
rescue missions before daylight
yesterday and are continuing that effort
today
by the end of yesterday they had already
saved hundreds of lives and completed
thousands of structural assessments
allowing people to safely return to
their homes Federal teams are continuing
to assess damage and work to restore
critical Services ensuring emergency
power is available to critical
infrastructure like hospitals and
evaluating Bridges airports and ports as
well we're also continuing to support
the people of Puerto Rico as they
recover from Hurricane Fiona we're
providing support for emergency response
recovery and power restoration efforts
and recovering one and covering 100 of
the cost of Public Assistance debris
removal and more we have a we have over
1 000 Federal response workers on the
ground and we are providing millions of
dollars to repair highways and bridges
as well we are also investing millions
of dollars to make Puerto Rico's
infrastructure include shooting its
power grid more resilient to climate
change the people of Florida South
Carolina Puerto Rico and everyone
impacted by these storms have the full
support the full support of the federal
government and as you can see today
finally we are joined by National
Security advisor Jake Sullivan at the
podium to talk about the United States
response to Russia's attempts to Annex
parts of sovereign Ukraine and with that
I will let Jake take to the podium go
ahead Jake thank you for being here
thank you Kareem
uh as Korean said I will have an update
for you all on Russia but first I want
to take a moment just as Karine did to
acknowledge the devastation of hurricane
Ian and the millions of people who have
been impacted by this terrible storm and
as Karine said and the president said
earlier today our hearts are with the
people of Florida South Carolina and the
southeast
as President Biden made clear we're
going to do everything we can across
this white house and across this
government to support the people who
have been impacted by the storm with the
full resources of the federal government
as communities Endeavor to recover and
then to rebuild I also want to say a
special word of thanks to our First
Responders at every level of our
government for everything they are doing
and for the life-saving and dangerous
missions they've undertaken over the
last two days to keep people safe and if
you'll indulge me just a word on what
was a very important foreign policy
development yesterday
uh President Biden hosted a historic U.S
Pacific island country Summit
he released the first ever U.S Pacific
island strategy he announced over 810
million dollars in additional expanded
programs to help these countries combat
the climate crisis provide development
assistance enhance Maritime security and
more and finally President Biden and all
12 Pacific island presidents who joined
him here at the White House for this
Summit issued a joint declaration to
strengthen our partnership and to chart
an affirmative vision for the region
today as you all saw just a little bit
ago President Biden issued a strong
condemnation of Russia's fraudulent
attempt to Annex Sovereign Ukrainian
territory
this act is a flagrant violation of
international law and it has no
legitimacy
unfortunately it's also not surprising
it's straight out of Putin's Playbook of
Deceit disinformation and aggression and
we've been warning about it for months
in fact I've stood at this Podium and
warned about it several times including
as recently as last week
based on our information every aspect of
this process was pre-staged and
falsified under orders from the Kremlin
the Sham referenda were held at gunpoint
Ukrainian civilians were forced to cast
ballots through coercion intimidation
and in some cases under the watch of
armed guards
saying that it somehow reflects the will
of the people is an absurdity
the United States will never recognize
these actions the world will never
recognize these actions and we will stay
the course as the president told you
earlier today we have built LED and
maintained an extraordinary and
coordinated response with our allies and
partners and that response will continue
as President Biden said we will not be
deterred so what does that mean
specifically in reaction to What has
just happened first
as we saw from the treasury Department
as the President underscored we are
sending a clear warning from the United
States government supported by all of
our G7 partners
we will sanction and impose export
controls on any individual entity or
country that provides political or
economic support to these attempts at
annexation
we have put in place authorities to
enable us to do that rapidly and
efficiently
we are also announcing new sanctions
today that Target additional Russian
government officials and leaders
including State Duma members who are
accomplices in these fraudulent actions
and including the Central Bank governor
we are also sanctioning Russian and
belarussian military officials and we
have specifically targeted defense
procurement networks including
International suppliers supporting
Russia's military-industrial complex
second we will continue to provide
military equipment so that Ukraine can
defend its territory and its freedom
today President Biden will sign
legislation from Congress that contains
more than 12 billion dollars in
additional funding for Ukraine and we
are grateful for the continued support
there is no stronger more bipartisan
rebuke of what Russia has just done no
more timely rebuke and no more assertive
statement that we can make through
resources and not just through words
that we are going to continue to help
Ukraine defend its territory and to
deoccupy those parts that Russia has
occupied
earlier this week we announced a
significant new billion dollar arms
package which included 18 new high Mars
for Ukraine as part of our long-term
commitment to strengthening Ukraine's
Armed Forces over the years ahead and we
expect to have another announcement of
immediate security assistance to
announce next week
next the United States and the
International Community have been
crystal clear that we will use
diplomatic tools at our disposal to
fundamentally reject Russia's attempts
to take its neighbor's territory by
force today the United States is
supporting a resolution at the U.N
security Council to condemn these sham
referenda and to call on Russia
immediately to withdraw its forces from
Ukraine if Russia seeks to Shield itself
at the security Council the United
Nations will work with Partners around
the world to take action next week at
the U.N General Assembly
leaders around the world have spoken out
about what's at stake the independence
of the democratic nation of Ukraine the
principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrity and the Very
foundation of the United Nations United
Nations Charter and the modern
international order as the Secretary
General of the United Nations said
yesterday quote it must not be accepted
and it will not be accepted to put it
simply the regions of Donetsk luhans
kirsan and zapparisha remain Ukrainian
territory Ukraine has every right to
continue to defend its sovereignty which
the people of Ukraine are doing bravely
and courageously every day with the
support of the International Community
and the United States for our part under
President Biden's leadership will
support them at every step along the way
for as long as it takes and with that
I'd be happy to take your questions yeah
Ukraine is seeking accelerated
membership in NATO is that something
that's possible or something you would
seriously consider the United States has
been clear for decades that we support
an open door policy for NATO any
decision on NATO membership is between
the 30 allies and the countries aspiring
to join right now our view is that the
best way for us to support Ukraine is
through practical on the ground support
in Ukraine and that the process in
Brussels should be taken up at a
different time yes thanks Jake in his
speech this morning the president called
the Nordstrom pipeline attacks uh quote
a deliberate Act of sabotage and he said
now the Russians are pumping out
misinformation and lies about it should
we take that to mean that the U.S now
believes that Russia was likely
responsible for this act of sabotage
well first Russia has done what it
frequently does when it is responsible
for something which is make accusations
that it was really someone else who did
it we've seen this repeatedly over time
but the president was also clear today
that there is more work to do on the
investigation before the United States
government is prepared to make an
attribution in this case one of the
Practical reasons for that is that
because gas is emanating from these
pipelines the Danish authorities and
other authorities in the Baltic Sea
can't actually get down to the source of
the leak to do forensics on what appears
to be an explosion so we will have to
wait until the combination of physical
inspection intelligence gathering and
consultation with our allies to make a
definitive determination but what we can
say unequivocally is the suggestions
Russia has made about the United States
and other countries are flat out false
Russia knows they're false but of course
this is part of their playbook how many
countries or entities are even capable
of carrying out the kind of attack that
we saw with hundreds of kilograms of
explosives 250 feet below the surface of
the sea not many and I think this is
obviously an act of sabotage that took
place we believe in the neighborhood of
70 to 80 meters 230 to 270 feet under
the ocean you know that takes some
degree of sophistication but I don't
want to get ahead of myself in terms of
asserting how exactly this happened or
who exactly did it until we're standing
on Solid Ground we will continue to work
with our allies and partners to gather
all of the facts and then we will make a
determination about where we go from
there two questions
clearly had nuclear weapons on his mind
today when he was giving his speech he
said the West is deceitful hypocritical
the United States is the only country to
have used nuclear weapons and he said by
the way they've created a precedent how
worrying is that to you I've been clear
myself President Biden has been clear
our Administration has been clear that
there is a risk given all of the loose
talk and the nuclear saber rattling by
Putin that he would consider this and
we've been equally clear about what the
consequences would be we have
communicated that directly to the
Russians we do not presently see
indications about the imminent use of
nuclear weapons we are of course
monitoring that carefully and staying in
close consultation with allies and
partners but this is something that we
are attuned to taking very seriously and
communicating directly with Russia about
including the kind of decisive responses
the United States would have if they
went down that dark Road it's the risk
of that higher now than it was six or
seven months ago well what's interesting
is that at various points over the
course of this conflict including right
at the outset Putin has brandished the
nuclear card he's doing it again so the
risk has been there from the start it's
there today I'm not going to
characterize its exact level only to say
that we have been taking this seriously
for some time and we continue to take it
seriously now one broader question
before we move on what lessons from 2014
and from Crimea are you using now what
did you learn from that that you're that
you're applying here
well there's a number of um just in
terms of the tactics of how things
unfolded in Crimea including the fact
that you didn't have the kind of uh
sustained military conflict associated
with it that you do in these cases that
means you cannot draw the analogy too
far on the other hand one of the things
that we have been clear about from the
start of this conflict and even in the
months that preceded it when I stood at
this Podium and warned that it was
coming is that we were going to be
prepared with clear Swift and very
certain responses and so when I stand
here before you today to talk about
sanctions to talk about new funding to
talk about new transfers of military
equipment and diplomatic initiatives
that are unfolding the very day that
Putin gives his speech that is all the
product of months of planning and
coordination with our allies and
partners so that we do not allow time to
elapse so that we seize the Diplomatic
initiative and so that we communicate
very clearly we will not accept this and
we will help equip ukrainians to push
back aggressively against it even as we
rallied the International Community to
condemn it that has been our strategy
from the start we have tried to be as
clear and transparent about that as
possible warning what was going to come
indicating what we would do and then
following through and doing it and
that's what we're doing today yeah Jake
would the U.S act
said before that we have had the
opportunity to communicate directly to
Russia a range of consequences for the
use of nuclear weapons and the kinds of
actions the United States would take I
have also said before that we are not
going to Telegraph these things publicly
and so all I can tell you is that the
Russians understand where things stand
on this issue we understand where things
stand on this issue and I will leave it
at that you run the risk though we're
not moving more Firepower to Europe
right now that we would be unprepared
for a serious response if he were to
take that kind of action tomorrow
President Biden even before this
conflict began moved a substantial
number of additional U.S forces on land
sea and air to Europe after the conflict
got underway within 72 hours he had
ordered the movement of even more forces
beyond that so we are standing at a
level of enhanced Force posture across
the Eastern Flank In the major Maritime
domains and with all of the capabilities
we need in the air as well we feel that
we have in place right now the capacity
to effectively deter and respond to any
contingency and to make good on what
President Biden emphatically reinforced
today that we will defend every inch of
NATO territory the United States has put
in place the pieces for that and if you
look at what our NATO allies have done
in terms of surging their own
capabilities to Eastern flank allies
upping their own defense expenditures we
are at a level a state of Readiness to
take on any contingency and we're doing
the active coordination and scenario
planning to be prepared for whatever
comes our way is there anything we can
do to protect energy infrastructure now
before something that's actually in use
gets attacked in Europe the president
mentioned today actually in response to
a question that we have in fact begun
coordinating with allies to increase
surveillance and monitoring of energy
infrastructure including pipelines in
the Baltic Sea and we will continue to
work closely with Norway and other
countries that have come out publicly
and announced that they are stepping up
their efforts in that regard the United
States has capabilities to be able to
bring to bear and we are bringing those
to Bear can you describe a little for us
about the scenario planning I would
think that when this War Began there was
a certain category of planning that has
gone on and how significantly has that
changed as the facts have changed as
these threats have changed and does it
suggest that this is a very Dynamic
situation where is the president engaged
in approving new plans on a frequent
basis or is this something that is part
of a of a ready play book that would
already
be at the disposal of the Department of
Defense or is this something that's
being retooled in real time there are
elements that are consistent and
elements that are Dynamic and what I
mean by that is from the very beginning
we've known the broad categories of
forms of escalation that Russia could
conceivably undertake we've known the
broad categories of contingencies that
we might face our allies might face and
Ukraine might face but of course as time
goes on and circumstances change on the
battlefield and broader diplomatic
circumstances change and as we gather
new intelligence we can refine the
contingency planning within those broad
categories to be more specific about
different scenarios and so over time the
president gets updates on the
intelligence updates on the likelihood
or lack like lack of likelihood of
different circumstances and refinements
in the planning that's taking place
across every element of our government
including the defense department the
intelligence Community the state
Department usaid the department of
energy the department of transportation
we have people experts from across our
government working on a range of
contingencies and the president is in
regular touch with his National Security
Council principles to get updates on
this and to give direction about how to
continue to refine and sharpen these
plans the other thing that's happened is
you've seen this steady stream of
Engagement engagements President Biden
has had with foreign counterparts
particularly in NATO the G7 European
Union that has been an opportunity to
engage on different scenarios and to
make sure that the leaders of these
countries are directing their teams to
coordinate together so that we can have
a common playbook for how we respond in
different circumstances that's been a
very important planning function that's
almost unprecedented in the intensity
and frequency of engagement at the
leader level in a circumstance like this
yeah I want to ask you about the
sanctions I mean know we've had batches
of sanctions rolled out for the last say
seven months and I wanted you to help us
understand what makes you all confident
that these latest sanctions would deter
or change Putin's behavior when thus far
we have not seen
it well so first one of the key elements
of our sanction strategy has been to
reduce the capacity of the Russian
military machine to regenerate uh its
ability to threaten Ukraine and we think
we have had an impact on that denying
inputs to the weapons of war that Putin
wants to manufacture in place on the
battlefield second we have wanted to
undermine Russia's major sectors in
technology in industry and of course in
defense so that its capacity to project
power threaten and coerce its neighbors
and wage Wars of aggression is reduced
over time and we think that there is
demonstrable progress on that front as
well third we want to send a clear
message to the rest of the world
that those companies those individuals
and those countries
that are going to stand beside Russia on
this issue of illegal annexation they
will subject themselves to sanctions and
we do believe that that will have a
considerable deterrent effect and have
seen that in other circumstances so for
all of these reasons we feel that the
sanctions element of our strategy the
economic pressure that we are placing on
Russia and the denial of their ability
to gather what they need to be able to
regenerate their War Machine this has
been a critical element to how we have
prosecuted our strategy so far and the
impacts of it will continue to be felt
month on month as we go forward and put
us in a stronger position and Russia in
a more disadvantaged position as this
unfolds
real quick on sort of the broader view
of U.S policy on annexation is it U.S
policy that any land gained by defensive
or offensive War
um cannot be legally annexed
it is the U.S policy that the attempt to
Annex at the point of a gun
to conquer territory old sham referenda
and then declare that territory your
Sovereign territory and not your
neighbor's sovereignty is as flagrant to
violation of the U.N Charter as possible
and this case is cut and dried and it's
for that reason that the U.N Secretary
General who has been a careful voice a
neutral Arbiter in multiple efforts on
diplomacy between Russia and Ukraine
over the last six months came out with
an absolutely unequivocal statement in
this regard yesterday and every word of
it is something that the International
Community can collectively stand behind
yeah do Russia's actions give you any
second thoughts about enacting the oil
price cap policy which essentially would
you know encourage countries to buy
Russian oil at a discount as opposed to
a loud Global ban
we're continuing down the road of
negotiating alongside our G7 partners
and working with countries who are
purchasers or prospective purchasers of
Russian oil what the parameters in terms
of a price cap would look like we are
not currently discussing a change in
that policy but rather continuing to
find ways to both protect Global energy
markets and to deny revenues to Putin to
feed his war machine that is our
fundamental objective we believe this is
the best method by which to achieve that
objective and we're not looking at a
fundamental course correction on that at
this time yeah are we concerned there
could be attacks on U.S and Western
infrastructure after the Nordstrom one
incident
we have to be concerned about the
possibility of Russian action Russian
aggression against Western
infrastructure Western facilities we
have been concerned about that from the
beginning of the war we don't have any
specific intelligence to share with you
today on that but that is the reason we
do contingency planning it is the reason
that we send strong deterrent messages
like the president today saying that the
United States will defend every inch of
NATO territory and it's why the
president said today that we've elevated
our surveillance and monitoring of
critical infrastructure in NATO
territory in the event that it is put at
risk either physically or through cyber
means or otherwise and we will continue
to do that there is a heightened concern
about that
well before this war even began I stood
at this Podium and said the possibility
that we could see attacks in the United
States cyber attacks where we could see
attacks in Europe whether physical or
cyber was real it was real then it
remains real today and what happened
with Nordstrom one and two only reminds
us that it is real yes thank you
um there is a clear mixes between Russia
and Europe
regarding the Drone program that
threatened Ukraine how worried are you
about this and is any way to stop it and
will you impose more sanction on Iran in
the aftermath of the killing of Miss
amini that yourself condemned and also
they issued some sanctions but we expect
more sanctions on their mission
we continue to condemn the brutality and
the repression against the brave
citizens of Iran the brave women of Iran
who are simply Marching for their rights
and their dignity and their Justice and
we continue to stand with them not just
in word but indeed we have issued
several sanctions against Iranian
entities for what they have done in this
killing and brutality and yes we will
continue to look for targets to impose
sanctions uh in response to these brutal
human rights violations we have also
issued sanctions with respect to the
transfer of uavs from Iran to Russia and
we are looking for additional methods to
reduce Iran's capacity to be able to
manufacture and then to sell these kinds
of systems to Russia we will continue to
work on that and the entire world should
see that Russia as it runs into problems
being able to regenerate its own
capabilities has to turn to other
countries to try to get a hold of
whatever kind of precision munition it
can including Iranian uavs that this is
a move Russia has been forced to make
because it is being denied inputs and
we're going to try and cut off other
countries who Russia would
seek to go out and approach to get these
kinds of weapons to be able to feed
their War Machine in Ukraine yes I very
quickly ask what the profile of weapons
and stuff being said is changing in
particular whether you have a view on
whether tanks
invited to Ukraine either by the us or
by other countries facilitated by the
U.S and separately what we have here has
been about a year since that office deal
was announced I want to hear any update
on the status of that or the Australians
going to be buying American submarines
British submarines or a combination of
the two actually our leaders just
recently put out a statement following
the one-year anniversary of the August
announcement which took place last
September just over a year ago and we've
made substantial progress over the
course of the past year we feel very
good about the trilateral cooperation on
the submarine program we think that we
have a good path forward I'm not going
to get into specifics on exactly what
the nature of the platform will be that
some of the details of that need to
continue to be worked out but even more
importantly I need to protect the
sensitivity of it I will just say that
our three countries are very much on the
same page about the path forward and
there has been significant progress from
concept one year ago to now the process
of actually putting this in place we
also are pursuing a significant number
of advanced capabilities through the
August partnership in cyber artificial
intelligence in other areas we've seen
significant progress on those as well
and there are certain areas where we are
looking to bring in other partners as
well as part of an open platform
approach with respect to tanks we
actually have facilitated the provision
of Tanks to Ukraine from some of our
Eastern European Partners who have
provided the same type of soviet-style
tanks that the Ukrainian Army trained on
and is in possession of and we will
continue to do that in terms of other
weapon systems what the president
announced this week was a further
provision of highmars which we have
provided before we expect the next
package will be a re-up of many of the
capabilities that the ukrainians have
moved so effectively and I don't have
any announcements of new and additional
capabilities
sorry a NATO standard tanks Abrams Tanks
leopard tanks like a higher more modern
tank that's what it's being thought by
either the Ukrainian advocates for it is
are you ruling that out or is NATO
ruining that out I'm not ruling anything
out I will say I don't have any
announcement on a U.S tank today and in
terms of German tanks I would refer you
to the Germans who are in their own
consultations with ukrainians
Senators Blumenthal and Graham introduce
legislation yesterday that would cut off
U.S military and economic aid to Nations
that recognize Putin's annexation of
Ukraine does the White House support
this proposal uh or would it consider
such a policy movement like this so I
haven't had a chance to read the
legislation in in these circumstances
the details end up mattering but at a
broad level the basic proposition that
we should be imposing economic costs on
countries individuals and entities that
are providing political and economic
support to these annexations not only do
agree we agree with that I just
announced that from this Podium today we
are going to do that ourselves under
executive Authority and I want to issue
a clear warning to those who would think
about providing political and economic
support to these annexed territories
order Russia's efforts to justify and
defend the annexation
you can be subject to U.S sanctions as a
result of those activities we look
forward to working with Senators Graham
and Blumenthal on an approach in the
Congress that could be consistent with
and help drive that forward
a couple
of um I'd like to get the
administration's reaction on President
zelenski's statement saying that we are
ready for a dialogue with Russia but
with another President of Russia that's
my first one and then the second one is
we understand that U.S diplomats have
been pressing Russia's allies to
convince Putin to de-escalate can you be
more specific about those kinds of
overtures in what ways does the
administration believe that China and
India can apply more pressure on Moscow
to de-escalate not go the nuclear route
so on on your second question we think
any country that believes in the
principles of the UN Charter and frankly
that should be every country that signed
up to the U.N Charter I should be taking
on its measure of responsibility to
communicate directly to the Kremlin
Kremlin that what it is doing is wrong
it is unjustified and it must stop and
we are asking that of countries around
the world we'd like them to speak out
publicly and we would like them to
convey things privately diplomatically
with respect to the first question which
was I'm sorry zelensky saying that he's
ready for a dialogue with Russia but
with another President of Russia
president zielinski has consistently
said throughout this conflict that the
war ultimately uh will end through
diplomacy and we have consistently
backed him up in that I would have to
refer you to him on that precise
statement and what he means by it but
what I will tell you is that we have had
daily engagement with President his
chief of staff his foreign minister his
defense minister uh and much
communication of course between our
military and their military to make sure
that we are understanding one another
well that we are transparent about the
support we're providing and the strategy
they're pursuing that continues today
and that will continue every day from
here on out share the sentiment of
president zielinski that a dialogue is
only possible with another president and
not Vladimir Putin I don't know the
context of the statement unfortunately
so I can't answer it in the
characterization you've just provided it
what I will say is that President Biden
believes that a diplomatic solution in
Ukraine is possible but it is only
possible according to the basic terms of
the U.N Charter that everybody signed up
to that's what he said in his U.N speech
last week he continues to believe that
quite strongly and in his conversations
with President zielinski they've been of
the same mind on that point
on the pipeline did I hear you correctly
to say that the US government has ruled
out the involvement of any European
allies including Eastern European
countries some of them are very angry
about that Pipeline and in the sabotage
and that we do not believe that this was
the work of any NATO Ally and then more
broadly Putin in his speech cast this as
a kind of cultural struggle with Russia
standing for tradition at the U.S and
the West standing for Satanism attacking
the family and traditional uh values and
things like that how do you how do you
answer that argument
it's it's raving
this the fact that he's using words like
Satanism is to me precisely the kind of
over-the-top rhetoric and ranting that
you hear from someone who has no basis
to justify what is a colonial and
Imperial land grab
and so rather than fill in any kind of
logic or moral defense of what he has
done he has to resort to these kinds of
absurd arguments and I think that can be
plain for the entire world to see yeah
and how much this would be the last one
so thank you Jake I want another topic
what is your expectation for the
election in Brazil this Sunday what are
you going to be watching for and how
fast is the White House
going to recognize the result once he's
announced I don't make predictions about
American elections so I promise you I
will not make predictions about
Brazilian elections or elections of any
other country
thank you guys question about Ukraine
thank you thank you so much Jake we
don't have much time because I know
folks have to gather but Colleen you
want to kick us off sure
um cream can you give us an update on
who the president's plans uh will he go
to Florida with the go to go and then
also
um do you have any idea how much money
you'll have to request from Congress yet
to replenish
the uh disaster fund so um I'll say this
the the continuing resolution in
Congress as you all know is uh voting
they're voting on this all today so
we'll help ensure that FEMA has the
resources it needs to address immediate
response and Recovery needs including
those in Puerto Rico and also in Florida
so we will remain in close touch
obviously with Congress on on continuing
that continuing to evaluate that as far
as as what's currently happening uh look
the president's been very clear he wants
to focus on what Florida needs what
Puerto Rico needs and we they both have
the full force and the full support of
the uh the federal government and we
will continue to have close
conversations uh with the officials on
the ground to make sure that they have
the people in Puerto Rico and the people
in Florida have what they need as you
heard he he spoke to the South Carolina
governor today offering those same uh
kind of that same support support one of
the things that I just want to reiterate
which is really important about what we
have seen these last couple of days more
actually more than a week is if you
think about what the president was able
to do in Florida and what the
president's going to be able to do in
South Carolina which is preposition
federal employees responders on the
ground in a way that we have not seen
before it is unprecedented what we're
seeing the type of coordination that
we're seeing on the ground and so that
is because the president has made this a
priority and he wants to make sure that
we are you know we are offering all of
the support just to name a few because
this is uh we think important it's the
FEMA Urban search and rescue uh the U.S
Coast Guard the Department of Defense
DHS the department of the Interior
working hand in hand with the Florida
National Guard and state and local
responders and these teams are doing uh
the work day and night to make sure that
they're rescuing folks on the ground but
also offering water food and generators
as well
when the president does go to Florida
whenever that might be does he want to
meet with Governor DeSantis personally
so I you know I want to be very clear
about this when this is not about
politics right this is about uh this is
about the people of Florida and what
they need when we saw Surfside the
horrible uh um catastrophic uh you know
building falling in Surfside and killing
so many uh Floridians not too long ago
over a year ago you saw Governor
DeSantis and you saw this President sit
side by side talking about how they were
going to work together to make sure that
that Community got everything that they
need so this is not about politics I
don't have anything to share about a
trip that the president's going to be
making he spoke for himself yesterday he
is something that he wants to do when
it's appropriate in Florida it's he does
want to also go to Puerto Rico and once
we have an announcement to make we
surely will make that announcement
apparently abused today between the
administration and oil Executives could
you tell us a little bit about that
what's that for for sure um so
what I understand like as you stated
there is a there's a meeting that
happened with the Department of energy
with the oil companies don't have
anything to share at this time as to how
that meeting is went or what's uh what
the uh what was on the agenda but
certainly it is an important meeting as
we look at continuing to keep those gas
prices and oil prices
down for the American people as soon as
I'm sure there's Bill readout and some
more information to share to all of you
okay yesterday President Biden said that
Governor DeSantis when they spoke
complimented him and praised the
immediate response from the federal
government is that a sentiment that the
president returns does he think Governor
DeSantis has handled the response as
well so far so I can't I can't
um I can't speak to the specifics of a
private private conversation I can say
that you know we gave a readout from our
end about how the conversation how the
conversation went again we don't want to
make this about politics we don't want
to make this about you know red States
versus you know blue States this is this
is about the American people that are uh
you know families and everyday people
who are on the ground who need the
assistance and they are going to
continue to coordinate they are going to
continue to have conversations they have
I believe three conversations in just a
week's time about what they can do to
help the communities uh in Florida but I
I don't want to get into to politics
here because this is not about that
right I'm not asking about politics I'm
just asking if the president thinks that
Governor to San Diego I'm just not gonna
I look I haven't had that conversation
with the president what I can tell you
is that they are working uh closely uh
together the FEMA administrator is down
there currently with the governor they
are traveling uh the state together and
looking at um what is currently
happening on the ground uh I'm not going
to get into particulars or who's doing a
good job and who's doing a you know I
don't know uh I don't know could do a
better job I should say right now we are
working closely hand in hand with the
officials on the ground we have had
multiple conversations not just this
president but also the FEMA
administrator and you can see the fact
that they've had conversations the fact
that the FEMA Administration
administrators on the ground that this
is a working relationship that is about
the people of Florida I'm not going to
get into scorecards here
yeah uh thanks uh just uh real quick is
the president the president will sign
the CR today is that the idea I don't
have any that's a very good question I
don't have any specifics on that I know
it takes some times like the there's
mechanics that need to be handled on the
Congress side before a Bill gets here
don't have any specifics on when they
get signed clearly he will sign it as
soon as he's able to do that okay and as
the is the White House still committed
to an early October uh timeline for the
application for students
I do have a little bit um I don't have a
specific date in October but let me just
since you mentioned uh the email uh
yesterday we began the first of what
will be regular updates uh to borrowers
interested in debt relief we shared
information of what people can expect in
the coming weeks around the program and
process for applying we shared the
following the application for debt
relief will be available next month in
October no date set yet but we will next
month it's this month we are in October
right or tomorrow tomorrow we're in
October the application will be a short
online form borrowers won't need to
upload any documents or use their fsaid
to support their application the
application will be available from
October 2022 through December 2023 once
an individual submits a form the
Department of Education will review the
application determine if the individual
is eligible for Relief and will work
with their loan server to process the
relief our goal as you all know and we
have said this is to provide borrowers a
seamless and simple experience working
closely with the server the servicers
who will actually process the relief we
will have additional information for
borrowers and in the upcoming days again
I know you're asking for a specific date
but that was what we provided in the
email and we should have more student to
share we have any weak ahead guidance
for next week I know that you don't want
to say anything about the trip to Puerto
Rico or Florida you know we usually put
out our weekend heads for for those who
who uh who follow their week aheads
coming out of here on Sundays if there
is a trip next week we certainly will
will share that with you don't have
anything to announce at this time at the
podium on Fridays as much as possible
trying to give someone a kid no I
understand we've been here for 19 months
and we've always done the weekend heads
on Sundays I I know I hear you I get it
but I'm just I'm just oh yeah that's
right we just don't have have I I hear
what you're saying we just don't have
anything today on for Friday to share I
get the question I got it but normally
yes we do our week aheads that we send
out on Sundays and you're right we used
to do that on Fridays I just don't have
anything to share and we will we will
try it and and uh be more proactive in
doing that on Fridays for sure go ahead
Jackie thank you
the president
uh to investigate instances of price
gouging but John Kirby said yesterday
that there haven't seen any evidence of
that happening and I remember the
president first put out this this call
for the FTC to investigate possible
price gouging in November of last year
so my question to you is why does he
keep throwing that out there and does it
have anything to do with the possibility
that OPEC announced a production cut
next week and we might start to see
prices come up is he trying to deflect
away from so as you know we're not going
to speak to OPEC OPEC plus we are
clearly not uh not a partner or part of
OPEC plus so we they are an independent
entity and we allow them to make their
make their news and their announcements
on their own uh what we what we're
saying is we're just making sure that
while we're while people are dealing
what we are all dealing with a hurricane
uh that gas and oil companies don't take
advantage of it it's just uh it's just a
a little bit of a hey we we want to make
sure in this time when people are losing
their homes when people are dealing with
incredibly difficult time that we
shouldn't take advantage of it that's it
it is just coming from the president and
we feel that coming from the president
is is a powerful voice and so uh look we
don't we know that disruptions from
hurricanes can pose challenge to markets
but the but the latest projections show
that major Refinery should not be
impacted by Hurricane uh Ian and so uh
so we're just making it very clear to
the oil companies the president is
making it very clear to the oil
companies so there's nothing more to it
than just being just Vigilant about that
does it all run the risk though further
fraying the relationship between the
administration and these there's been
you know obviously some space between uh
you know their position industry heads
position and the the White House in
terms of attitudes toward fossil fuels
and you know sort of casting of blame
from side to side they the companies
will say able the fight Administration
is hostile and that's why you know we
can't ramp up Productions does this kind
of rhetoric I mean so as you know the
oil companies are currently meeting with
uh uh with uh officials White House
officials and the department of energy
um and so look I think the president
thinks that he is standing up for the
American people and making sure that oil
companies are passing on the savings
that they're getting to Consumers and we
have said that time and time again and
this is something that the president
thinks it's important to use his
platform to do so
uh thanks Kareem um can you give us uh I
know you're not going into the week
ahead but for the weekend President
Biden is in town he's going to the
Congressional Black Caucus dinner
tomorrow night are there other things
he's doing this weekend anything related
to the hurricane that he's playing too
well he is getting regularly uh daily
updated on uh hurricane Ian uh as you've
heard him say many times if we have
anything else to share we certainly will
as I mentioned administrator uh Criswell
is in in Florida so she'll when she
either before she gets back or when she
gets back she certainly will give the
president an update on what she saw on
the ground so that'll be very important
and she has spoken to him many many
times multiple times this week so again
he'll get a daily update as he has been
for the past week or so on both
hurricane Fiona when that was happening
currently with this hurricane and we
will have more to share if there's any
other calls that he makes on the ground
with officials as well the other thing I
wanted to ask was you had said the other
day that Jackie family was going to be
here today for a bill signing has that
happened is it happening it wasn't on
the schedule yeah as you as you all know
we don't put every Bill signing uh on on
the schedule uh as you can imagine this
is a personal a personal moment uh that
that the president was doing uh you know
like I mentioned in the briefing a
couple of days ago and as you just
stated the president has been you know
looking forward to hosting uh the late
Representatives family and other
lawmakers to to honor her Legacy and and
he is signing the bill naming a post
office in her memory and that is
happening it was happening when we
started uh the briefing so I haven't
gotten an update on how that went but
clearly this is uh this is an important
uh this is an important uh moment for
her for her family and so I can give you
a little bit of who was in the meeting
so that you all know it included the the
late representative's uh husband mother
brother staff and several bipartisan
members of Congress speaker Pelosi
minority Kevin McCarthy representative
Jim Baird representative Jim Banks so
this again happened while we were while
I was coming to to the podium and as you
know the majority of Bill signings are
not necessarily always done in public
and so this is that example as well so
Kevin McCarthy was here for the bill
signing is that the first time he as he
met I don't have a kind of a you know a
data or on when he's how many times he's
been here so I can't I actually can't
speak to that at this time but he was
here for this particular Bill signing we
have to remember that the issue that she
fought so hard for on on ending hunger
uh ending child uh child hunger and
specifically has been an issue that's
been bipartisan and that's what we saw a
couple of days ago from that Summit
yeah thank you uh the education
department yesterday uh tweaked uh some
eligibility issues with the student loan
forgiveness plan that uh basically
saying the borrows with Federal loans
that are owned by private banks are now
ineligible to affect uh perhaps 770 000
borrows I've also seen a couple couple
million just curious uh is that a
disappointment for the White House that
you have to make this change seemingly
around some legal issues and could there
be future changes uh before applications
are made that could narrow eligibility
further was or is the plan uh final now
so first I just want to make sure
because I know this was out there that
the number of borrowers impacted or uh
or a change in this change is is much
smaller I know there was a number of
millions but it's actually it's actually
much smaller so our goal from day one
has always been to deliver relief to
many borrowers as possible as quickly as
possible and this change helps us
achieve that so we will continue to make
sure we zero in on that look the
Department of Education continues to
explore alternative ways to provide a
relief to those borrowers with with
commercially LED held held loans I do
want to say that you know when you think
about uh what we're trying to do right
we're trying to give relief to to
Everyday Americans right we're trying to
give relief to uh Working Families we're
trying to give a relief to working
Americans and the fact that you see
folks out there in Republican states
that are making it very hard for us to
do that for us to give a little bit of a
breathing room to working Americans I
think it's uh it's it's really
unfortunate because what we are doing is
actually popular with Americans what we
were doing is actually giving Americans
an opportunity to put money down on a
house an opportunity to start a family
and so uh that is what uh unfortunately
we're seeing that it reads these red
State
Republican officials are doing and
remember this is going to help 40
million Americans who truly really need
just a little bit more space do you
anticipate though that the plan is now
final or could there be other
modifications like this before I don't
want to I can't speak to to that what I
can say is we're going to do everything
that we can to explore alternative ways
to give relief to those borrows these
particular bars that that you were
asking me about that are uh that are uh
that are with commercially held loans
and so we're going to do everything that
we can department of education education
is going to do everything that they can
again this is about giving relief a
little bit of breathing rooms some extra
extra kind of opportunity for folks to
really uh you know be able to to to get
that house again to start that family
and so that's what we're going to
continue to focus on I think I have to
to go I'm getting the uh but I'll see
you well next week and we will we will
have a week ahead as soon as we can
thanks everybody
[Music]